this will close out with some
relationship advice oh hell yeah hi Theo
eye Brennan this is Arthur come to you
all the way from Massachusetts first of
all love the show you hit Meatwad
thank you guys for what you do but I'm
looking for dating advice so right now
somebody that I work with is trying to
set me up with one of his very close
friends which already I'm a little
hesitant because I don't want to make
things weird between me and him right or
things weird in the office but I also
not sure that me and his friend are
right people for each other
and here's what so she is apparently an
ex-marine
she's a self-described dedicated redneck
and stricken for you recently I guess
she had to be held back at a party from
beating the [ __ ] out of someone so I
guess she's got an attitude which all
wrong girl he just goes on to say he's
more peaceful chill guy might be a
little Union a yang hmm she might yet it
sounds very dangerous I think you should
go for the ride oh yeah if I can save it
private right here dude you get in there
dude [ __ ] what's wrong with dating GI
Jane maybe you're called to some mud
yeah so you get your dick sucked dude
it's a good time yeah that's true it
could be real outdoorsy it could be it
seems like I don't know if you're
already nervous about it she's gonna
sense that man and probably pounce on
and I feel like you know she might beat
you up yeah she sounds very tough I
don't wanna you know it's hard if you're
trying to like like feel a chick up and
her tits are real hard
it's also hard if you're trying to feel
I mean she's a huge [ __ ] didn't say [ __ ]
at all that we don't know it sounds like
she's real aggressive she has a beard if
all we know it's the only fact he gave
us I'm just piecing things together
trying to help homeboy out man oh yeah
my bad we're trying to help him out I
think you go on a date with GI Jane see
how it goes and keep us posted
yes I know some military chicks dude
they're some of the baddest women the
earth you know I'm saying I ain't
talking about them shootin [ __ ] Isis
I'm talking about some just baddies yeah
underneath that camouflage some [ __ ]
hush puppies hmm yeah they got some real
real sweet gals out there in the
military and I'll say this also dude you
sound like a nice guy you seem like
somebody that's nice you know you're
able to drive you have two arms I saw in
the video you're a healthy guy good
video clear yeah you're working
somewhere you're employed got a chin
yeah and now you're gonna risk it all
for GI Jane for whatever yeah whatever
Rambo you know this female ramble ramble
ramble ah yeah I go on a date with RAM
Bell and keep his [ __ ] posted dude
it's like he's scared man he's gonna be
in a neck brace she's gonna [ __ ] he's
gonna throw her and she's gonna throw a
grenade in a second yeah her her way of
foreplay is waterboarding you dude I
made love to a woman one time down there
in Guantanamo Bay down there and uh she
had a grenade yeah in the trunk of her
car and she said well go off I don't
know dude she just it was cool man it's
nice to you know it's nice to have a
grenade around die hard baby and you're
meeting somebody it's interesting it's
fun so I think there's a good
opportunity there to meet somebody
that's really exciting but I don't want
you to see you get hurt man I think you
ought to the nation she served four
years for your [ __ ] freedom I was
talking suck on a tip yeah your little
piece of [ __ ] hook up with Ron betta and
let us know - yeah when you put it like
that man get out there and freakin
salute them what did you do for the
country yeah get out there and salute
that broad brother you got this man who
look out there
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]